hi my name is Ariane Shirin and I've
written the cover feature for this issue
of The Spectator it's all about self
marriage there is women who have decided
to marry themselves and many of them
have decided this because there is a
lack of successful eligible men and they
think that rather than settling for
somebody who are they're not mad keen on
they've decided that they're going to
embrace singledom and embrace themselves
so when I first heard about self
marriage I thought all that sounds a bit
depressing but actually after
interviewing all the women I completely
changed my opinion it is a really kind
of brave and lovely way to celebrate
your own life and your own decisions and
it's about being autonomous it's about
being a modern woman and not having to
wait around for mr. right not having to
wait around for a knight in shining
armor but making alternative
arrangements and if you want to have a
big day with a perfect dress and look
amazing and have all your friends there
and all your loved ones and all your
family but you don't have a guy then why
not it doesn't hurt anybody and I think
it's a really positive thing to do